المازق الفشل العار بعض من كلمات لا تخلو
منها احاديث
الاسرائيليين يتحدثون منذ فجر السبت عن
ثغره امنيه لم تشهدها تلبيب منذ هزيمتها
في حرب اكتوبر من عام
73 انه طوفان الاقصى وقد جرف مليارات
انفقتها دوله الاحتلال منذ نشاتها على ما
تسميه الاغراض الدفاعيه
يصنف الجيش الاسرائيلي في المرتبه السابعه
عش بين اكثر جيوش العالم انفاقا بميزانيه
دفاع تتجاوز 24 مليار دولار سنويا كان لم
يكفي الانفاق الداخلي اذ تحصل اسرائيل من
الولايات المتحده التي تصنفها حليفا
رئيسيا من خارج النيتو على مساعداتها
العسكريه الاكبر وقدرها 3 مليارات و800
مليون دولار
سنويا ما كانها من شراء احدث المعدات
العسكريه الامريكيه وبناء احد اقوى الجيوش
في
العالم جيش يصنف ضمن اقوى 18 جيشا في
العالم وفقا لاحصائيات موقع جلوبال فاير
باور الامريكي للعام الحالي ويضم هذا
التصنيف القوه الاجماليه للجيش الاسرائيلي
بجميع اسلحته وافراده سواء اكانوا في
الخدمه او ضمن القوات الاحتياطيه او من
القوات الشبه العسكريه كانما تبخر ذلك
الجيش الاسطوري وكل عتاده وتلاشت نظريه
فائض القوه اذ تجلى على الحدود ضعف
الاستعدادات القتاليه للجنود الاسرائيليين
وحداتهم
العسكريه الاخفاق الاخر تبدى في انكشاف
سهوله اختراق التحصينات العسكريه هناك بكل
ما تشمله من جدار وحواجز اسمنتيه واسلاك
شائكه والكترونيه وتقنيات رصد متطوره فكان
توغل المقاومين وسيطرتهم على معابر حدوديه
وقواعد عسكريه ومستوطنات في العمق
الاسرائيلي تم ذلك تحت غطاء صاروخي عر مره
اخرى قله حيله منظومه القبه الحديديه
المكلفه ومعها مقلاع
داوود تعددت مظاهر الاخفاق الاسرائيلي اذا
على المستويات التكتيكيه والعمليات
والاستراتيجيه لكن الفشل المدوي سيق حتما
في سجل ما يصنف بانه احد اقوى اجهزه
الاستخبارات على مستوى العالم اخفق جهاز
امن الشاباك في توقع هجمات المقاومه
المنسقه باحترافيه عاليه فال التكنولوجيا
وانظمه التجسس ولا عباقره وحده النخبه كما
يسمون ولا العملاء على الارض امكنهم قراءه
الموقف القراءه الصحيحه ان افلتت من
الجميع خطط وعمليات اعداد وتجهيز
من افراد المقاومه
الفلسطينيه السؤال يطرحه الكاتب
الاسرائيلي حيم لنسون في مقال له بصحيفه
ارت عنونه مهما حدث في هذه الجوله من
الحرب فقد خسرنا بالفعل يقول الكاتب ان ما
حدث ادى الى انهيار الشعور بالامان بين
الاسرائيليين وكشف عوره الجيش الاسرائيلي
ووهن